A little mystery always keeps things more interesting
That's why introverts are one of a kind
With their unique insights, it's no surprise that many people fall for them
But how do we know if their feelings are mutual?
Here are 13 subtle signs an introvert likes you
1. They actually pick up the phone or call you
This is especially true for restrained introverts
This type of introvert is reserved and slowly opens up to others
If this sounds like your crush
slow and steady wins their heart
Preferring to think before they speak, texts are more of their speed and they often avoid phone calls
But if they make an exception for you, that's incredibly special
2. They invite you into their personal space
Introverts like their space, especially after a long busy week
But if they make plans with you to go over to their place
whether it's for dinner or a movie
it means that they prefer your company over their solitude
3. Or they accept your invitation and go out
Meeting you faces and socializing can be intimidating
especially for social introverts
They often enjoy the comfort of their own home
and don't go out of their way to attend parties
So pay close attention to just how willing they are to leave their comfort zone just to see you
4. They remember details about you
Speaking of close attention, introverts make natural detectives
Do they know you like the back of their hand when you've only mentioned things once?
If they remember your birthday, your favorite things, your favorite Kpop group
and notice all the small details about you
there's a good chance that they might have feelings for you
5. They don't shy away from personal topics.
Thinking introverts have a knack for being deep in reflective
This makes it easy to be mesmerized by them in good conversation
When they talk about sensitive topics, whether it's about their tough childhood or losing a loved one
it's because they're also enjoying what you offer to the table
6. They become more romantic overtime.
With extroverts, the flame bursts the most at the very beginning, but introverts operate on their own clock
When it comes to bonding, their affection for you grows stronger overtime.
Introverts are slow at opening up
So the more your connection strengthens, the more affection it may become
You'll never have to worry about the excitement dying out
7. They keep your secrets and share theirs, too
Winning the trust of introverts is often as slow-downs
You must learn to sway before you tango
That's why it's so big when they've learned to keep your secrets, and tell you theirs.
8. They always keep in touch with you
This can be hard for them, especially for anxious introverts
Self-conscious and painfully shy,
they often seek solitude but sometimes the anxiety doesn't go away
even when they are alone
If you catch one who makes an effort to stay in touch
it means that they feel comfortable around you, and that's a plus in their book
9. They show you their collections
It's nerve-wracking for introverts to tell them how you feel
So they may resort to their favorite poetry or music collections to do all the talking
Yes, it's cheesy but you have to admit it's also really cute
Bonus point is they show you something that is  sentimental or personal
like a journal entry or a secret art piece, too
10. They're loyal to you.
Introverts make great partners because once they like you, they'll become protective
Although they don't like conflict, they won't shy away from it if it means that they're looking after you
11. They go the extra mile
both literally and figuratively
They enjoy their space so long distance relationships don't scare them away
If they're always checking on you and go out of their way to do you favours
they definitely have a soft spot for you
12. They give you feedback.
We all get a little frustrated along the way when we try to achieve our dreams
But you can always count on an introvert to offer great advice
If they always catch you when you're falling, you're a star in their pocket
13. They step out of their comfort zone.
Introverts are wild differently than extroverts
and prefer to watch on the sidelines before jumping in
But when an introvert likes you, they're willing to make a move and try something new
Do any of these signs resonate with you?
Do you love an introvert?
I know I love an introvert
I also learn about whether you're on an introvert's bad signs
Check out our videos here
And thanks for watching!!